please welcome the European commission
president Ursula vanderlen
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening it's a pleasure
and an honor to be here tonight and
speak at this esteemed Gathering
about an ally and a friend
and a most deserving recipient of this
award prime minister fumio kishida
I could tell the audience about our
amazing cooperation of these years dear
prime minister
about how we coordinated our actions in
the wake and in the aftermath of
Russia's full-scale aggression of
Ukraine
or how you hosted an incredibly
successful G7 net Hiroshima
but there is another moment that is even
more telling of your courage and your
leadership
I'm talking about your visit
to the small Ukrainian town of butcher
a symbol of Russia's brutality
and of Ukraine's resistance
butcher was liberated by Ukraine's brave
soldiers in the early weeks of
but Russian troops left a trail of blood
and death and destruction
they executed dozens of civilians In
Cold Blood
in one of the worst war crimes since the
start of Russia's brutal War
and you
dear fumio
decided to make the long and difficult
trip to butcha
to see with your own eyes the horror
that Russia left behind
but also Ukraine's determination to
resist
and to fight for its freedom
for the first time since World War II
a Japanese prime minister visited a
country of at War
and you brought with you Japan's
solidarity
in words and deeds
from the very beginning of this war
you opened your country to Ukrainian
refugees
you joined us in sanctioning Russia for
its crimes
and you stood at our side when Putin
tried to Blackmail Europe with gas
Ukraine and the whole of Europe will be
forever grateful to you for this
arigato diaphumio
[Applause]
you have done this
because you know
that although ukrainians are paying the
highest price
this war is not only about Ukraine
and it is not only about European
security
this is about the basic principles of
the UN Charter
which have protected Global Peace since
the end of World War II
it is about the simple
yet vital role rule
that borders cannot be changed by force
and that every country should be free to
chart its own path
you dear form you
understood this from day one
you understood
that we must all contribute to upholding
the U.N Charter
because in a lawless World any country
might face the same fate as Ukraine
in your words
you said
Ukraine today
maybe East Asia tomorrow
end of quote
European security and indo-pacific
security are one and the same
your vision of a free and open
indo-pacific is also our vision
so we are bound to work together
and in these two years prime minister
you have forged ever stronger ties
between Japan and your like-minded
friends near and far
from East Asia to Europe and North
America
you have reconnected Japan to its most
trusted partners and build new Bridges
across the world
thanks to your leadership today our
three continents are closer than ever
before
distinguished guests
there is a Japanese proverb
that tells a lot about the country
and about its prime minister
it says
and it means
explore the past to learn new things
you dear prime minister
showed me the meaning of this proverb
during the G7 Summit in Japan last year
you brought us to your hometown of
Hiroshima
the place
where you have your roots
and which has deeply shaped your life
and Leadership
many of your relatives lost their life
when the atomic bomb raised Hiroshima to
the ground
you have grown up with the stories of
the survivors
and you wanted us
to listen
to the same stories
to face the past and learn something
about the future
it was a sobering start to the G7 and
one that I will not forget
especially at a time when Russia
threatens to use nuclear weapons once
again
it is heinous
it is dangerous
and in the shed of Hiroshima it is
Unforgivable
no one is better poised than Japan
to warn us of the extreme danger and of
this recklessness
right from the beginning of this war
Japan's position was clear
as the only country that has suffered
from a atomic bombings
you have made the whole world listen
today Russia's nuclear Sable rattling
has been condemned not only by our
like-minded partners in the G7
but by the whole world
and your diplomatic efforts have been
crucial to reach this outcome
this is true leadership
the kind of leadership that the world
needs in these troubled days
leadership that is not afraid to learn
from the past
to shape a different future
so it is a pleasure to be with you today
to celebrate your work and your vision
distinguished guests
please join me in congratulating prime
minister kashida on earning the 2023
Atlantic Council award
foreign
your kind introduction
we are good friends for long
and it makes me especially happy that
you talk only good things about me
tonight
thank you very much
and thank you president Kemp and the
Atlantic Council for this prestigious
award
I'm very much honored to receive this
in May
I hosted
the G7 Summit in Hiroshima
a symbolism of the Pledge for peace
at The Summit
this G7 leaders and many other leaders
from around the world
had the opportunity to directly listen
to the experiences
stories
wishes of hibacha
the survivors of atomic bombings
as well as to learn firsthand the
devastation through their visit to the
Hiroshima Peace Memorial Park
there we share
in A Renewed determination
to work together
towards the world without nuclear
weapons and to pass on the same
conviction and resolve to the generation
that will follow
ladies and gentlemen
here in Manhattan
there is a large statue of Buddhist monk
this statue stood in Hiroshima 78 years
ago and it survived the atomic bomb
every year
on August 6th
citizenship in New York
Gather in front of this statue and pray
for peace and a world without nuclear
weapons
hibaksha
and the citizens of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki have devoted their lives to
sharing their stories and prayers
many others too have dedicated their
lives to promoting nuclear disarmament
or advancing radiological Sciences
today
let us remember
those who gave their lives and
sacrificed everything for peace
all of us here as standing on the
shoulders of those unsung heroes
we should never let their efforts and
sacrifices
and as a mere dream
it is the responsibility of every
political leader to find Pathway to
overcome the harsh realities of the
world
and take the lead to achieve such peace
I humbly accept this award
on their behalf as Prime Minister of
Japan and as a citizen of Hiroshima
thank you very much
[Applause]